y
[Música]
i
con el regreso a clases cara a cara
inició la reapertura de inglaterra que
se ha mantenido en un estricto
confinamiento desde el pasado 4 de enero
también con estas nuevas reglas se puede
ver un amigo en un espacio abierto como
en un parque y también se permite
visitar ancianatos esta es la primera
etapa de cuatro para establecer una
nueva normalidad se espera que en julio
además se prevé que con el regreso a
clases y aunque los estudiantes de
escuela secundaria tienen que hacerse
una prueba del cob y dos veces a la
semana los casos de contagio se disparen
entonces el gobierno evaluará si se
puede pasar a la siguiente etapa para
abrir uno los negocios y los comercios
no esenciales entretanto en el reino
unido se han vacunado 22 millones de
personas más de 22 millones de personas
ha recibido al menos la primera dosis de
esta vacuna contra el coronavirus
[Música]
la situación del joven 19 vuelve a
preocupar a las autoridades en francia
sobre todo de la región de ildefons que
es aquella a la que pertenece la ciudad
de parís y una cifra es la que más
inquieta la tasa de ocupación de los
servicios de reanimación que llega un 88
por ciento son los mismos niveles que en
noviembre pasado el 60 por ciento de los
enfermos allí está contagiado de la
variante británica pero también preocupa
la tasa de incidencia esto es el número
de nuevos casos semanales por cada
100.000 habitantes en todos los
departamentos de la región de parís
sobrepasa los 250 casos que es la cifra
que fijaron las autoridades sanitarias
como suelo de alerta por lo mismo esas
autoridades pidieron a los directores de
los hospitales que aplacen un 40 por
ciento de las cirugías que tenían
previstas para hacer espacio a los
pacientes kobe lo que ha despertado
varias voces de protestas
pero pese a estas cifras llegaron
salomón el directora de salud de francia
ha dicho que la solución por ahora para
la región de parís no es un nuevo
confinamiento que no estamos todavía en
una situación de explosión epidémica
[Música]
en las últimas semanas ciudades como
estas se han convertido en una de las
principales preocupaciones de las
autoridades alemanas
estamos en flensburg en el norte del
país en la frontera con dinamarca una
ciudad que ha estado particularmente
afectada por una de las variantes del
coronavirus con una incidencia muy alta
y también bajo restricciones estrictas
es por situaciones como estas por
lugares que han estado muy afectados por
las variantes que las autoridades
alemanas decidieron alargar las
restricciones generales hasta finales de
mes y también es por situaciones como
ésta que las autoridades tanto a nivel
federal como regional decidieron
elaborar un plan de reapertura gradual
cauto que depende específicamente de la
incidencia tanto a nivel regional como
local y que por cierto también incluye
un llamado freno de emergencia por el
cual se imponen nuevas restricciones
para los lugares que se vean
particularmente afectados por el
coronavirus
[Música]